stuff your mouth hole with Mama's
delicious balls and be prepared to never
look at a hand dryer the same way
because
holy a lot is happening that's right
Emma my beautiful giantess we have
another action-packed episode of genv
that makes me proud my member is still
intact and in this video we'll be taking
a deep dive into the episode its
connection to the comics the boys and a
whole lot more and be sure to stick
around till the end of the video where I
go over the trailers to sleuth out what
might be happening in the weeks ahead
now make sure to smash that like And
subscribe button it's the only way I can
afford vot plus vot plus the world's
Premier super streaming service sign up
now thank gulan my hearing isn't as bad
as Greg's the guard who Emma AKA Little
Cricket brewed her way through at the
end of episode 3 he's been kind of a
running gag the last two episodes as the
guard no one really cares about well I'm
Greg hey Greg will clean up later let's
go Dr endir shett has come to inspect
the aftermath math of Sam's escape with
Dr cardosa here revealing that Sam was
stronger than Golden Boy ever was but
why was Sam experimented on against his
will no less remember that Sam used to
be institutionalized at Sage Grove the
same place the boys broke into in season
2 but something happened in the last 3
years that prompted VA to move him to
the secret location known as the woods
could an event that happened and the
boys have triggered VA to create this
secret program remember VA created
compound V to produce superpowered
Heroes could the woods be a program to
take those away with gulan serving as a
fresh pool for new subjects in my
episodes 1 to3 video I theorized that
gulan is actually a prison Marie has to
walk through these metal detectors the
doors are made of reinforced steel like
a jail cell and Emma remarks that the
windows can't open nor can break Sam's
Escape puts Dean shetty's job at risk if
VA finds out they have a soup on the
loose a dangerous one from a secret op
no less her life is on the line remember
last episode that VA CEO Ashley Barrett
warned Shetty that if word of the woods
got out it could cost them their lives
Shetty finds the cutest little shoe from
Emma now we didn't get a confrontation
between Emma and Shetty this episode but
no doubt she'll be using Emma to try and
get to Sam somewhere on the outskirts of
Campus Andre and the Gang have found
enough time to get out of their Gala
attire and locate Emma's tracker this
was given to her by Andre before she
embarked on her quest to find Sam take a
look at the this meteor likee crater
which the others assume was likely
caused by Sam who has the ability to
jump long distances like Queen May we'll
see him do this as he leaves the
drive-in as Marie chastises Andre for
putting her roommate up to this
Extremely Dangerous Mission the trustees
have come out with new rankings the last
time we had an update was in episode 2
and the only real change of note here is
Marie moving from rank eight to Rank 2
Jordan calls the woods a mangala health
clinic a reference to Joseph mangala A
Nazi physician who conducted Ed inhumane
and deadly experiments on prisoners at
owitz sounds a lot like Frederick VA who
before defecting to America was a
prominent Nazi geneticist at the
abandoned Drive-In a place Sam and Luke
frequented as kids we can see an
interesting movie plays Red Thunder
starring Soldier Boy which we saw a
brief clip of in season 3 and I'll stand
by our mujahadin brothers Until the End
Sam wants to see his brother but Emma
has to break it to him that Luke killed
himself something Sam doesn't take too
well it's seems that everyone in Sam's
life leaves him and he fears Emma will
leave him too I also thought it was
interesting how Emma in her small form
jumped off this huge ledge and survived
so she's got to have some form of super
strength as well on vot plus everyone's
favorite streaming platform sorry Amazon
Tech Knight's hit show the whole truth
plays notice the suspiciously circular o
in whole something that makes a lot more
sense when we find out Tech Knight's
fetish for holes we'll see him Rim this
class some Scotch tape and steal a
circular Bagel in the comics Tech Knight
was an original member of payback the
1980s crime fighting force we saw in
season 3 and he was more a parody of
Iron Man than how he's depicted in gen V
now this isn't the first time Tech
Knight has been mentioned in the boys
Universe in season 1 at a meeting for
those who were collateral damage in soup
attacks Sheila the paraplegic says After
All Tech knite saved me I just wish he'd
been a little more gentle with my spine
we can even see a newspaper clipping of
this incident in mother milk's Closet in
season 3 the deep talks about how he
convinced Tech knite to drive a hybrid
mean you take Tech Knight's night racer
had a carbon footprint the size of a 727
thanks to me now he drives a hybrid in
season 2 after Stan Edgar chastises
homelander he reminds him that he has a
tech KN Night movie premiere to attend I
believe you have a premiere of tech
Knight lives to go to Tech Knight has
been tasked by Ashley Barrett to use his
show and influence to help cover up the
reason behind golden boy's death and
this will be done by finding a a student
to blame it on and there's no one better
for the task than a suu's powers are
perfect for interrogation he can sense
elevated heart rates beads of sweat and
even how long have you been eating
golden boy's girlfriend's ho that too
his methods have resulted in death with
Dean Shetty reminding him how ironcast
killed himself the morning after Tech
Knight interrogated him we've seen
ironcast and the boys present diabolical
episode 3 but in that version he's
killed when the Great Wide Wonder flew
through his chest one of the things I
love about this scene is all the stuff
that's happening that isn't expressed
through words for example Tech pours the
dean a drink gives it to her and later
in the scene she pours it back into the
decanter little stuff like that just
makes the scene all the more interesting
and what would have otherwise been in
mostly an exposition Dum now Tech wants
to see Sam not knowing that Dean hasn't
told anyone he's missing this could
prove disastrous for her if tech finds
this out and reports back to Ashley
meanwhile Andre deals with his anxiety
by getting high and crashing with Kate
he hasn't had the time to process that
his father the superhero known as
polarity not only knows about the woods
but is actively covering it up it's sad
that Andre so wanted to be like his
father when he was growing up and now
that's all put into question Rufus
everyone's favorite homelander Jumanji
loving Clairvoyant is watching a whole
truuth episode on shaho a parody of
She-Hulk from the comics who at one time
was under consideration to be a member
of the seven before vot landed with
Starlight Marie has arrived hoping to
use his powers to find Emma but Rufus
being the little horn dog that he is
wants her to get a little closer that's
when she somehow passes out and awakens
in his dorm room to find him naked and I
got to admit this gives off rapy Vibes
although Rufus says quote this is not
what it looks like is he telling the
truth here does his power perhaps
require him to get naked and is the
blackout Marie experienced here
connected to the one we'll see her have
at the end of the episode not a huge
spoiler but the trailers do show us
Rufus will be in more episodes with his
manhood seemingly intact did it
regenerate or maybe it never happened in
the first place some sort of effect of
rufus's power even though Marie handles
Rufus just fine on her own Jordan knocks
down the door and rescues her warning
Marie that Tech Knight is on campus and
if he gets to her it could seriously
screw things up Tech Knight proceeds to
interview Andre Jordan and Kate using
his powers to determine what caused
Golden Boy to snap did he find out that
Kate was cheating on him with his best
friend is that why he blew himself up
Andre storms from the interview stating
what kind of hero to chicken to do
anything heroic this is what separates
him from his father polarity is more
interested in the fame associated with
being a superhero than actually saving
people back at the theater Emma has
morphed to regular size and we see some
really cool posters like red Thunder 2
and a romantic comedy starring Soldier
Boy and Crimson cess called hero seeking
hero and after a delightful conversation
about nipples Sam opens up about how
it's scary being on the outside without
his brother he always had Luke and now
he has nothing but it looks like Emma is
going to be there for him signifying the
start of a romantic relationship in
superhero branding class Dean Shetty is
concerned that Marie hasn't been
stopping by for lunch last episode Marie
had developed a pretty strong friendship
with the dean even coming over for
breakfast but at the gala it was
revealed that Dean was basically using
Marie as a fundraising tool putting into
question the genuiness of their
relationship shedy wants to know if
she's seen Emma no doubt probing Marie
on the whereabouts of the girl who
infiltrated the woods but Maria says she
has no idea even though Marie doesn't
volunteer special guest speaker Tech
knite demonstrates his interrogation
techniques to the class eventually
getting Marie to disclose the truth that
it was Jordan who held off Golden Boy so
she could get away Jordan is the real
hero this pisses off Shetty who reminds
Tech Knight to lay off the top five
students but he actually has other plans
instead of pinning golden boy's mental
break on a student he's going to pin it
on her he knows about Sam escaping the
woods and just wait till VOD hears about
this Sam schizophrenia manifests in the
form of TV's Jason Ritter starring at a
puppet show called Avenue V at take on
Avenue Q This Vision outlines his
greatest fear that not only will Dr
cardosa come after him but now Emma too
and that if anything happens to her
it'll be his fault he couldn't protect
her this prompts him to go after Dr
cardosa without Emma no doubt he doesn't
want to see her get hurt this is also
the second time we've seen the deeps
gills talk although in season two they
were voiced by Patton Oswalt
she just put her hands on your chest you
never even unzipped your suit nothing
like crushing your famous father's
statue who already had part of his dick
smashed in I really hope over the course
of the Season his statue just gets worse
and worse Jordan here now has the balls
or lack of balls depending if she's in
girl form to get pissed at Marie for
telling Tech knite she was the real hero
odd considering this is what Jordan
wanted in episodes 2 and three Jordan
wants her to tell the truth but not if
it means bearing Marie in the process
and this Revelation that Jordan actually
cares about her leads to a kiss Jordan's
interest in Marie was hinted at very
subtly in episode one I told was
you yeah she's cool Emma barges in on
their make out SES to warn them of Sam's
intent to kill Dr cardosa and thankfully
Jordan knows where he lives because he
had access to his information while
working as Brinks ta meanwhile Dean
shett has brought Tech knite to a
secluded area of the woods to Blackmail
his ass somehow she has access to his
medical records and has found a small
tumor in his brain this tumor not only
being fatal but is also the source of
his fascination with holes in exchange
for leaving alone her and God you she
won't make publicly truly horrifying
security tapes Tech knite agrees and
we'll see his conclusion of the Golden
Boy case as simply being the story of a
student who snapped Sam has Tracked Down
Dr cardosa and is ready to kill him when
Andre Marie Kate and Emma ared he thinks
Andre Marie and Kate are in on it and
rightfully so Andre and Marie caught him
the night he escaped not knowing he was
a prisoner and Kate used her power on
him to quiet him down years ago at Sage
Gro it's it's Emma however who saves the
day by getting big done by eating Mama's
meatballs she's able to pin Sam down
while Maria exclaims they're going to
make this right they're going to protect
him but suddenly the screen cuts to
Black and we're somehow back at the
gulan dorms with Jordan sleeping by
Marie's side what the hell just happened
now I have two theories here the first
it has something to do with rufus's
power since a similar blackout happened
to Marie earlier that day caused by him
the second is Sam himself remember that
he was able to give Golden Boy these
weird Visions if he was able to alter
golden boy's mind could he not do the
same to others and what is the extent of
this power but let's get into our
trailer sleuthing section and see what
else we can learn about this in the
season ahead be on the lookout for
Ashley Barrett here she looks completely
shocked at something I wonder if she'll
make a visit to God youu check out this
freakish pimply hand which seems to
belong to someone in the woods we'll see
other inmates experiencing some sort of
test that caused pain and maybe even
death in a redband trailer we'll see a a
woman in the standard inmate dress of
gray sweater and pants shooting laser
beams from her eyes perhaps trying to
escape we'll also see Jordan fighting a
girl in plain clothes with similar laser
beams but I can't really tell if they're
the same person or not more puppets in
fact we'll see Sam completely destroy a
bunch of Puppets perhaps this is his way
of dealing with the trauma of murder
it's easier to see them as puppets than
real people here he is holding a
decapitated puppet head in his Greg
jumpsuit we saw him wearing this episode
speaking of Sam here he is at the dorms
now I'm not sure if he actually becomes
a student or the gang brings him here
because they have no place else to take
him and here he is seemingly healed from
his dick explosion I could totally be
wrong but I don't think his dick ever
exploded rather the whole scene and
potentially Beyond had something to do
with his power here are some students
scrambling to escape the gulan dorms as
a huge metal gate shuts on them combine
this with Andre showing off these steel
Gates that cover up the windows and it's
just more evidence the dorms are some
sort of prison Victoria Newman tells
someone who I think is likely Marie that
it's her shot at real power she'll host
an event with what appears to be host
Cameron Coleman that sees both soup and
anti-p attendees someone here even with
a super scream ability here we have M
and Sam making out in front of a
polarity crane game are they back of the
drive-in or somewhere else we'll also
see puppet Emma another shot of Rufus
being pinned by Andre's ability to
control metal it looks like Rufus is at
some sort of party and we see Andre
throwing a keg at him and if the
trailers are any indication this isn't
the last time we'll see Golden Boy we
haven't seen this shot yet which means
we're in for either more flashbacks or
more than one Golden Boy but now I turn
it over to you what did you think of
episode 4 leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at@
thinkstory YT until next time remember
holy a lot is
happening